on prime crime do you remember what you
said
just stop just stop the predator no one
saw coming
one of the things that investigators are
looking for is what type of victim of
this person
looking for the unimaginable crimes
and i noticed that it has an erected
penis
he said do you see this do you like it
and how the drama unfolded in court it
definitely
definitely was a very stressful
situation
hey there everybody i'm jesse webber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high-profile and memorable true
crime cases
so we've covered sex crimes before but
some of the acts that you're going to
hear about
are as shocking as the identity of the
man that prosecutors say
committed them he goes i'm going to take
you to the store and i'm going to fuck
you
and and if you say anything
you know i will kill you
and i just froze then this is the
testimony of a 54 year old woman
who would come to be known as jane doe
won
she claims that on march 17 2018
out in california she was picked up by a
man in a jeep
and then he raped her he was on top
right he was on top of me
do yourself bleeding yes fast forward to
may 13
2018. did you have any indication that
you were in danger when you were in a
car he like helped me grab my arms
and um i don't know what else he said
but where
he says we're gonna have sex and i said
please don't do this
this is jane doe two a then 59 year old
transient woman
who says that she was sexually assaulted
he like
took off his pants did you see his penis
yes
i did at that moment i said no no no no
and then i
walked away a translator is speaking for
jane doe
iii a then 57 year old vietnamese woman
she testified that a man who identified
himself as
david exposed himself to her outside her
home
at first i think it was difficult for
the law enforcement to figure out who
was behind these these crimes jane doe
number one she didn't report the crime
until four days later
he was black he had lighter skin
his hair was like either it's been
crimped a lot it was just like an afro
type do you remember what type of car he
was in
yes what type of car was he it was a
black hummer
when you're dealing with a sexual
assault series one of the things that
investigators are looking for
is what type of victim of this person
looking for he looked like he was really
focusing on victims
that were a little more vulnerable
clearly
he had a predilection for older women
multiple victims
all seemingly unconnected attacks and no
perpetrator
that is until june 2018 when a man is
caught
sneaking into a san diego trailer park
home
law enforcement was confronted with
these 9-1-1 calls
from people saying that there was a big
african-american guy that was
in someone's mobile home i think that's
when it started triggering more of an
investigation
and then when one of the neighbors took
a picture of his hummer
i think that's when it started coming to
fruition for the prosecution
the burglary suspect would be linked to
the jane does
and he would eventually be arrested and
charged with nine
counts including kidnapping forcible
rape
and indecent exposure to the shock
of the world that suspect was kelen
winslow ii the famous nfl tight end
playing for teams like the browns
patriots jets and buccaneers
we have someone who is doing
phenomenally well
he comes from a legacy of football
players his dad by the same name was
also a football player
and then you have these charges coming
out and the first reaction you have
is why are you doing this winslow's
legal troubles though
only worsened another woman came forward
was he having sex with you at the time
that you became consciousness
yes jane doe number four said that back
in 2003
when she was 17 years old then 19 year
old kellen winslow
raped her at a house party do you
remember what you said when you were
telling him to stop
just stop just stop
did you become upset yes were you crying
yeah then in 2019
while winslow was out on two million
dollar bail he allegedly struck again
now he was accused of exposing himself
and masturbating in front of a 77 year
old woman at a gym
i have to look because he's right on my
face
and i notice that he has a erected penis
he said to me
with a very funny and happy face do you
see this
pointed his penis penis she said do you
see this
do you like it kellen winslow was
essentially in his prime he's in his
mid-30s at the time he's a very
successful
professional football player the fact
that these victims were all
pretty much elderly or or older in age
that was such a shocking fact to listen
to there was a lot that didn't quite
make sense about this case
and the government would quickly realize
there were problems in proving kellen
winslow
committed these crimes there isn't a lot
of forensic evidence of traditional
forensic evidence and that traditional
forensic evidence hairs fibers
fingerprints
dna there is some dna but not a lot
up next did winslow actually do these
things
you understand that you are under oath
yes not trying to give you trick
questions here these are just
straightforward questions
i said yes
when you screamed was that when he
placed his hands around your throat in
the way that you just described yes
so strong that i couldn't speak in 2019
nfl tight end kellen winslow the second
was in the spotlight
for all the wrong reasons he was accused
of committing various sex crimes with
respect to
five women mostly older in age
the question was how strong were these
cases against him
let's start with jane doe number one who
said winslow picked her up at his hummer
one night
and sexually assaulted her well when he
inserted his penis it hurt so bad
kept on saying ow ow ow ow because
i don't know how you fit that thing in
there and
i just i just felt this heavy gush
of water going what did you think it was
it was blood
she had kept her underwear and her pants
as she was wearing during the assault
and so we were able to get a combination
of blood
and semen from the pants and the
underpants
so that is a really big deal while it
would be confirmed that winslow's dna
was found on jane doe number one's pants
winslow never denied the encounter he
just said this was consensual sex
and that jane doe one was lying
i go just pull over right next to the
hospital how did you respond when you
told me he's like no
no way i'll kill you do you want to have
sex with him
no i thought that she definitely had
some credibility issues that she was
recounting what had happened
and i think that her stories just they
weren't adding up
they just didn't make logical sense so
we both jumped over the fence
he took his pants off and then i started
taking off my clothes
and um he goes
oh no let's just go back to the car she
didn't
try to get help she didn't run away even
if even though the attacker was on the
other side of the fence
she didn't call the police even though
she had the cell phone on her
as for jane doe number two who claimed
winslow raped her almost two months
after jane doe won forensic evidence
didn't quite support her account there
was no dna that they did the dna search
regarding the back of the vehicle the
hummer
and the front passenger seat and there
was not a match
for jane doe number two yet her eventual
testimony against winslow
was arguably the strongest piece of
evidence
can you tell us what you were feeling
when you did that um it's
painful did it hurt yes
i just kept my eyes closed she looked
like she was scared she looked like she
was nervous and even at one point she
said that
she didn't want to look at the attorney
cross-examining her because she didn't
want to see her rapist
i don't appreciate it i appreciate what
but i have to look at my rapist i
thought it was a very chilling part of
her testimony because
it just led so much credibility towards
her when it came to jane doe
iii who testified through a translator
and accused winslow
of exposing himself while she was
outside in her garden
are you uncomfortable talking about what
the man did that day
yes that is correct not only was this
allegation one of the most outrageous
but there was a serious issue regarding
identification
i saw his body only i didn't look at his
face
are you vietnamese yes i am
is there a habit or custom in vietnamese
culture
to not look at strangers directly in the
face
no yes that is correct she may not have
gotten a good look at the perpetrator's
face
but jane doe 3 did see something
what did you see on his arm i saw his
test tools from here
down to the wrist you are dealing with a
suspect who is
very distinctive looking big tall
athletic and
arm sleeve tattoos with very interesting
designs on them
and that's not all she noticed
did you see him with a bicycle the first
time you met him
yes keller winslow jr was a a fan of
strava
that that app that allows you to see
what kind of routes you're taking
whether you're running or whether you're
biking
his strava app was tracking where he was
going on that day and essentially put
him
one house away from her house and almost
the exact time
that she's saying that he was there
coming up
we'll take a closer look at the stories
of jane does four
and five which raise some questions
themselves
is this someone who is sort of jumping
on the bandwagon
in hopes of getting maybe publicity
themselves maybe a civil suit maybe
something
that would benefit them
did you call 911 what had happened
no i did not why not
i don't know i just didn't in 2019 the
sports world was in disbelief
that star nfl tight end kellen winslow
ii
was accused of committing various sex
crimes involving five different women
did winslow though really commit these
acts
jane does one and two claim that winslow
sexually assaulted them in 2018
and jane doe 3 says winslow exposed his
privates to her
outside her home in the same year then
there were jane does 4 and 5. i opened
my eyes
and my face was being pushed into
matt's groin area jane doe 4 says
winslow raped her when she was 17 years
old
back at a party in 2003 and in the
presence of another man
named matt she said after drinking she
lost
consciousness but remembers what
happened when she came to
what was kellen doing at the time that
he was pressing
your head towards matt's groin area he
was
penetrating me from behind
was he being forceful with you
yes 2018 did you receive some
information from the news
about uh a pending criminal prosecution
against mr kellen winslow yes
so all of a sudden i see his face and i
freak
i click on it and i'm just like no way
i start crying
i start thinking about what happened
helen winslow who is a very highly
acclaimed highly paid football player
and he's brought up on these charges
there's a lot of publicity surrounding
it
and now she comes out with her
allegations
on one hand you may say that okay the
other allegations and and people
stepping up and coming forward
may have given her the confidence to
come out but on the other hand you also
have to think from a defense point of
view
um are these claims credible this time
did you call the police
in 2003 to report what mr winslow had
done
i did not i didn't think anybody would
believe
anything i had to say as for jane doe
five
he was just touching and giving strokes
to his penis
she says while at the gym winslow
exposed and touched himself on a machine
nearby
then only days later she claims
he did something even worse what did he
do
when he sat next to you i could not see
but i
but i can think what he was doing he was
masturbating
jane doe number five was a firecracker
she was what 77 years old and she was
very firm in what she was saying these
incidents with jane doe number five
occurred after he went and already
posted bail
this is not just a one-time deal this is
a problem and a pattern of a sexual
predator
i think the defense did what they could
with jane doe number five angel number
five said that mr winslow had been
masturbating in the jacuzzi and of
course the defense attorney
really cross-examined her on the fact
that she couldn't see what he was doing
there were bubbles
he was a little bit away from her in
terms of distance and so this was all
speculation
the accounts of all five women came to a
head at
kellen winslow the second's trial which
began on may 21st
2019. the jury had to decide on 12
different counts ranging from forcible
rape
to lewd conduct we the jury find the
defendant
kellen boswell winslow ii
guilty of the crime of rape by
force or fear be the jury find the
defendant
guilty of the crime of indecent exposure
we the jury find the defendant guilty
of the crime of lewd conduct we the jury
find the defendant not guilty
of the crime of lewd conduct regarding
jane doe number five while the jury
convicted winslow of three counts and
acquitted him of another
they were deadlocked on the remaining
eight and a mistrial was declared
as to those charges and i think that the
defense attorneys did a really good job
of saying listen
you have to look at every person and
every victim
as they stand alone i think that some
aspects of the victim's testimonies
were believable and some aspects were
not
but there's more to the kellen winslow
story
what happened at his retrial surprised
many people the testimony you're about
to give will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth to help
you god
yes ma'am thank you more when we return
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
crime
will he had me take my pants off and
pulled me on from the seat you know
started to rape me
november 2019 kellen winslow ii
wants an acclaimed tight end in the nfl
with a bright career
ahead now was looking at a very
different and
uncertain future a few months earlier a
california jury convicted him of
forcible rape
indecent exposure and lewd conduct with
respect to several women
however the jury was deadlocked as to
eight other charges
the government pressed forward with a
new trial as to these counts
as both sides were ready to begin
something
unexpected happened have you had enough
time to thoroughly discuss this with
your attorneys
yes yes your honor okay i notice you
looked into the audience
i'm asking you i'm not asking anybody
else because sir this is
your decision and your decision alone i
think you understand that
you are pleading guilty that your
understanding of the plea agreement
yes yes instead of going to trial kellen
winslow announced his intention to plead
guilty to sexual battery of jane doe 1
and the rape of jane doe 4 while other
charges would be severed or dropped
this whole thing really just took place
off an offhanded comment that uh
that we had with the prosecution and
then it just sort of
uh blossomed from there he has a lot to
lose and in this particular case he was
looking at
potentially like 70 to life in prison
should he get convicted of any of the
multiple victims
and california life means life winslow
was giving up his rights to a jury trial
and to an appeal the gravity of this
decision became apparent
in court if you give up that right so
that you can enter a plea of guilty
you don't have to if you don't want to
as i said we have jurors out there
waiting
and they are willing and able to try
this case i guess i have to your honor
no you don't have to it's your decision
he understood what he was giving up you
couldn't tell what was going to happen
until the actual time where he was
entering the plea
it definitely definitely was a very
stressful situation
how do you plead to count six guilty or
not guilty
guilty you did unlawfully commit sexual
battery
against jane doe number one a 50 year
old 54 year old woman
how do you plead to that guilty or not
guilty
guilty i'm sorry guilty however
at a later hearing listen to what
winslow asked the judge
i want to ask a question i just wanted
to know if
if i was to go to trial would i give an
actual
jury of my peers that people of color
that would look like me when i get a
jury trial like that you cannot get to
another trial unless you make a motion
to withdraw your plea of guilty
and you can be sentenced up to 18 years
is that what you like to do because we
can end this right now
oh no no no no no i think it was really
uh interesting how kellen winslow
allocated to these pleas
he didn't seem particularly remorseful
was he taking a
real accountability as to his actions
and how this will play out which is
something which is
taken into account by the judge there
seems to be a
kind of a common thread among the
victims and
mr winslow you
carefully selected your victims those
that were most vulnerable
he kept going and i just
kept saying stop stop all right all i
know is it hurt
when you say that it hurt did you scream
yes the vulnerability of the victims was
no accident
it was it was the type of victim that
you sought out yourself
because you felt that perhaps they
wouldn't report the crime and if they
did
they would be subject to fierce
cross-examination and hopefully
probably you're thinking yourself they
wouldn't be deemed to be credible
as part of the agreement between the
defense and the state
judge bowman sentenced winslow to 14
years in prison
it shows how someone is not above the
law it doesn't matter how famous you are
it doesn't matter how much money you
have
if you do the crime you're gonna do the
time and i think that
helen winslow is prime example of a case
like that
and that's the story of kellen winslow
ii
the twists the turns the absolutely
appalling crimes
look we may never really understand why
winslow did what he did
but all that really matters is he was
brought to justice
and that's all because of the strength
of five brave
women and that's all we have for you
here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you